it was an effort created to help some
local residents who were struggling with
poverty during the pandemic
and today delivering with dignity
celebrated its one year anniversary
helping the community while also keeping
dozens of employees working
christian casares joining us in the
studio with more on the effort that has
really come a long way in the past year
that's right denise will delivering with
dignity started a year ago today as an
emergency response to the pandemic
they started delivering 3 500 meals
weekly and today
that number has almost doubled to 6 500
meals
every single week now the program works
with 50
non-profit groups to help identify
county residents who are struggling with
food and are at high risk of covet 19
when they step away from their home this
includes elderly folks people with
underlying medical conditions and
family members living in the same home
now the concept also helps keep
restaurant employees working
since they prepare the meals now for
locally independent uh owned businesses
who pack the meals are delivered by
volunteers to people's home
honeysuckle owner elizabeth blau says
the effort has provided critical support
to many restaurants struggling to keep
their doors open
this was a unique idea because we needed
to get these meals directly
to people's homes because community
centers and schools and senior centers
were closed and so those normal
distribution channels
became very very challenging to to
people
listen to this more than 325 000 meals
have been delivered since the program
launched
last march now they have reached almost
every single zip code here in southern
nevada
nearly 50 percent of those homes are
senior citizens
and 15 percent of them have children now
several donations
have kept the program going and allowing
them to expand to northern nevada very
soon now there are still
many people struggling to get food on
their table so if you wish to help make
a donation or become a volunteer
visit eightnewsnow.com for all those
details christian concedes 8 news now